[Music]
have you ever lost an hour or even two
on YouTube click on one cat video and
another one and ok just one more
it's hardly the worst sin unless it
leads not to cats but something more
dangerous the scale of YouTube is 1
billion hours being watched every single
day globally iam Joslyn is a French
software engineer he knows the addictive
quality of Li tubes algorithm because he
have to build it so our goal was to
increase watch time to keep people
watching more YouTube what works best is
to push them into a rabbit hole so
basically the algorithm in the last 10
years has been pushing people down
rabbit holes that are the most efficient
for which x PM says youtube's desire to
keep you watching thing has the
unintended effect of promoting
obsessions and extreme points of view
it's not trying to find what's best for
you YouTube is trying to push you down a
rabbit hole and whether it's like
terrorist rabbit hole or or make you
believe crazy conspiracy theories or
make you watch crap all day Ichi was
actively responded to claims of
misinformation banning far-right
activists to Tommy Robinson it told us
it no longer used to watch town as a
metric that it was not in its ethical or
financial interest to recommend harmful
content and that it had changed its
secretive algorithm they say that they
are a make they're making changes and to
be fair to them they have made some
changes but you if you go on YouTube any
day of the week you will still be able
to find extremist hate content racist
material very very easily YouTube says
its struggle constantly to stop its
users seeing inappropriate videos
removing more than 8 million every three
months but is this matter for anyone
more than teenagers and people who use
YouTube well none of these videos are
also popping up on the place the world
goes to for information Google that's
what I found and I've come to show my
findings to full facts the UK's leading
fat chicken charity show for fact
director will Moy what we
found hung up on dozens of Google
searches like this one with three of the
four videos repeated far-right tropes
it's great that YouTube provides a
platform for anything to say what they
want it's not so great but they're then
amplifying that to everybody who's
casually searching and that seems to me
a risk they don't seem to have fully
understood many of these videos stopped
appearing when YouTube which is owned by
Google purged far-right figures earlier
this month but we still found examples
so this relates to the conspiracy theory
that 5g kills birds I'm concerned that
when we look for information we ought to
get the stuff that actually helps us
make up our minds so Google really
matters it can be a gateway to lots of
new information for all of us that's a
massive benefit obviously but it does
come with risks if it then takes you
down a track which if you knew more you
wouldn't want to be taken down Google
and YouTube told us deliberate
misinformation online was a major
concern and that they'd been battling it
by cutting off some sites revenue and
prioritizing authoritative sources
especially on sensitive topics but faced
with intense political pressure and a
steady drip of negative news it may be
that only total structural reform will
be enough run a menthol Sky News